&gt;&gt; We can actually use slope intercept form to graph this line as well. We can
graph this equation by starting with the y-intercept or the b. So, I look on my
y-axis, and I go to 20 units. 0,20 my y-intercept. You can start at this point
because we begin graphing with the letter b. Now that we have the point of the
y-intercept, we can graph using our slope. Positive 2. I know slope is rise
divided by run. So, I'm going to write my number 2 as 2 divided by 1. Both of
these numbers are positive, so I need to move in a positive direction. I'm going
to go up two units and then right one unit. These are my directions for how I
should move from this point on the graph. I should move up two units, and then
right one unit. Notice that my y-axis is in increments of 4. So, I only need to
move up half that amount. Half that amount would be two units. Then, on my
x-axis, I move one direction to the right. So, I moved two units up, and then
one unit to the right. That gets me to my next point on the graph. If I repeat
this process, I can continue getting other points on the graph. I go up two
units, right one unit. Up two units, right one unit. I know it looks a little
funny on this graph, but it's because we've used a scale here. So the coordinate
grid doesn't match these numbers. It looks a little different.